(泣)
あの、おゆまるって
もう一度お湯に入れると、また柔らかくなるって聞いたんですけど
なりませんでした。
(泣き叫ぶ)
他の動画撮ろ 他の動画撮るよ！
おゆまるはまた今度することにします
なんでだろうね
よっしょい
はっ
ほいさ
今回はこちらを
買い物してきました
久しぶりのショッピング動画です
えと、今回ですね
パソコンを買いました
ああ
パソコンとか特にやりたくねぇな
では早速開けていきましょう
うっ
へぇ!　ほっ!　へぇ!
ふっ!
ん、待って
ゴォーンつったよ
のってきたぞ
アァーーー!!!
あの
この
開封の儀は
僕の、唯一の・・・
全く意味のない行為に見えるんですけど
運動不足の、僕からすると
唯一の運動なんですよ
はぁ
編集でカットしてさぁ、楽しそうに見えるけどさぁ・・・
大変なんだよ！！
はい、というわけで
新しいパソコンです。
ほい
パソコンの名前は・・・
とゆうものになっております
デスクトップPC
Macのパソコンだとできないこととかが結構あるんです
ゲームとかね
いろいろこう、Windowsでしかできないこととかもあるんで
Windowsのパソコンを買わせていただきました。
昔、Windowsのデスクトップ持ってたんですけど
ちょっと調子が悪くて、今のところ僕の持つ
唯一のWindowsのパソコンになります。
えっっ!?
待って
え・・・
待て待て待て
電源ケーブル
デュアルファン
プロセッサー
そして本体です
待てよ・・・、待てよ・・・(笑)
自作PCか？
待って待って待って
いや、これさ自作PCってやつかな
えぇー自作PC！？
待った
どうしよう　これ作れんのかな自分で
待った　ちょっ・・・とりあえず開けてみましょう
え、怖い怖い
できあがってるかと思ってたよ
え、これだ・・・これだけじゃダメなのかな
とりあえずこういう感じの顔になっております。
(ビニールを剥がす音)
待って、でも中身ねさぁ
あれ中身ないよ！
中身がない！
まさか・・・
えっ・・・
やったぁぁぁ！！
あ、てかそうだわ
そう書いてあったよ
この中の
そうですね、このパソコンは基本的には・・・
ゲーム用とWindowsでしかできない事用
3DSとかPSVitaとかのキャプチャーも多分
Win・・・あ、Macもいけるんだっけなぁ・・・
なんかMac用も出たみたいな話を聞いたことがあるぞ
わかんないんですけどWindowsのほうが
多分確実にできると思います
今後ねWindowsのパソコンが必要になるかな、と思いまして
購入いたしました。
マイクラとかもこれでいけるかと、思います。
一応ここがゲームする部屋なんですけども、
ゲームをする部屋に、パソコンをセッティングしようと思います。
やばい、もう遊戯王する場所がなくなっちゃうな
ここに、こうね、パソコンをしたい気分
ひとまずさっきのパソコン持ってこよう
思ったよりでかいな
置き場に困るな
むしろこっちに置いちまうか
ちょっと作戦変更でここにパソコンを置きたいです
ってかもう机をさぁ、こうしようか
机をこうしよう
あ、やべ、普通にお部屋掃除じゃんもう
こういう感じでパソコンをしたいんで、
机もちょっとグイっと回転させましょう
ま、折角の土日だからさ
今日はお掃除動画です
今日はお掃除するよ
あーっあっあっあっ
あっあっPCー
うわぁぁ！
待っ、待っｔああ！
遊戯王カード全部墓地逝ったわ
待っ、×△○§□¶
えっ、$#@△&{
おい
待ってこのパソコンなんですけど、
スペック良くて、安いんです
であと理由としては、モニターとマウスとキーボードが全部ついてません。
モニター
HDMI
イグニション
あぁーっ
ビール！！
マウスとキーボード
中学校の時に、結構パソコンが好きで、
なんかパソコン検定みたいなやつ持ってるんですけど、
パソコンの事は全くよくわかりません。
ちょっと最近ちょっとMacのパソコンを使ってたんですけども、
やっぱりね、Windowsよ
Macは使いやすくて簡単なんですけども、
Windowsのほうができる事が多いんで、
ちょっといろいろ試してみます。
というわけで、はじめしゃちょーの休日
新しいパソコンのこのシステムが完成したという感じでした。
では皆さん、よい休日を
じゃあな！